léo est en première année de staps
benjamins terminent sa licence le
premier a passé un bac pro en
maintenance industrielle
le second un bac s leur rencontre
n'aurait sans doute jamais eu lieu si
l'université n'avait proposé
d'accompagner les élèves venus des
filières pro et technique
l'ensemble des contenus de la l1 sont
répartis sur deux années donc on divise
le volume finalement chaque année par
deux et en accompagnement et bien on
leur propose des cours qui leur
permettent de réussir là où
potentiellement il échoue et donc
notamment dans les yeux scientifique où
ils ont l'équivalent des cours
d'enseignement en accompagnement faire
mal jamais les eaux assistent aux cours
avec les autres et complète part du
soutien
l'idée est de lui offrir les mêmes
choses qu'aux élèves venus des filières
générales car jusqu'ici le taux de
réussite des bacs pros ne dépassait pas
5 % et quitter c'est aussi de traiter
les profils différemment en fonction de
leurs besoins et certains étudiants ont
besoin d'un accompagnement plus
importants que d'autres pour réussir et
c'est justement là tout là tout l'enjeu
de la mise en place de ces dispositifs
individualisé car léo est également
suivi de près par benjamin l'un des huit
tuteurs étudiants qui reprennent les
cours avec le groupe des élèves en
licence aménagé on travaille avec les
enseignants justement pour apporter un
complément cours refaire certaines
parties du cours qui sur lesquelles il
pourrait être passé rapidement et qu'on
a besoin d'eux a expliqué on prépare à
temps partiel surtout surtout c'est
surtout sur cet axe con qu'on avance
au final ça va j'étais plutôt content de
faire ça parce que ouais avec en sortant
d'un bac pro en fait je pense j'ai plus
de difficulté que quelqu'un qui sort de
s quelle matière vous aurez le plus posé
de scientifiques surtout parce que nous
en bac pro 11 est de la mécanique
électricité
rien à voir quand même léo vient
d'obtenir haut la main son premier
semestre
son rêve de devenir prof de sport se
profile à l'horizon